I dislike the Andrew Tates of the world
and some of these red pill people who've
come up in recent years instead what
happens is Will men have it really hard
or or women have it really hard let's
hate the opposite sex also what these
people are doing some of the people that
we're discussing is they monetizing
resentment any ideology that wants to
push men and women apart is cancer half
of the core pieces of advice that some
of these people are giving like for
example test your girlfriend cheat on
her in what in what world in what world
is that is that logical to
anybody Sydney welcome to the show it's
awesome to have you here thanks for
coming all the way over uh before we get
into the conversation who are you how
are you where you are what has been the
journey through life that leads you to
be sitting here talking to us I never
know how to answer that when people say
broadly like give me your give me your
story the long and short of it is that I
started off in the political realm in
Australia I made a video back in 2018
that went viral and then very quickly
got picked up by Sky News Australia
which you guys should be very familiar
with Sky News because you have that in
the UK yeah um and Sky News Australia is
considerably more right-wing maybe what
you guys are used to yes and that kind
of just went from that point where what
was the video that went viral it was
about how you can't compare American and
Australian gun control laws or anything
related to gun control in in the two
countries cuz they're so different um
because people have this weird
philosophy when it comes to gun control
in the United States when they're
anti-gun control they try to emulate
Australia but it's not an Apples to
Apples comparison so I wanted to point
that out it angered it angered
Australians tremendously and so I got a
ton of uh push back and and hate and it
was really interesting because it was
the first time I thought online vit all
maybe is not for me um and then I kind
of just went from there where I kept
making content I kept growing I kept
getting bigger and then I thought I need
to do something more with this and so I
moved to the US and then was in DC for a
period which is an awful place to live
have you guys visited DC couple yeah I
don't I know what you mean um it's it's
interesting to visit but I definitely
would not want to live there no yeah
well that's well neither that's why I
moved it was at the sort of the
beginning of the pandemic I saw the
writing on the wall and I was like oh
God they're not going to let us leave
our homes or anything like that I'm not
going to do this so then I moved to
Texas and here I am still plotting along
on the internet lovely yeah so you talk
a lot about being conservative being
right-winged but what I find very
interesting Sydney is these words means
very different things in countries so
what does it mean to be right-wing or
conservative in Australia as opposed to
here it's actually that is a very
challenging question to answer as well
because I don't even think that
Australians know what being right-wing
is because I think that again everyone
tries to hold it up to the American
Standard which is this Christian hyper
conservative like small family units
nuclear family uh you know you go to
church on Sunday type of thing and you
believe that it's sort of like God Guns
and I don't know what the third thing
would be beer I don't know God God Guns
and barbecue yeah exactly now we've got
the barbecue thing
down wor about that um but it's that's
that is so hard to answer because again
if you if I were to be speaking to a
conservative Australian we probably
wouldn't align very much because they
are very much and aies will get so am
mad at me for saying this they're very
much about like Britain and the crown
they're almost like monarchists in a way
U whereas I think if you're just
generally rightwing in Australia you're
more Pro small government I guess
greater emphasis on freedom but they're
still nowhere near where Americans are
at there's just a lot of different
social things that Australians don't
actually care about and do you find
yourself aligning more with the American
right is that why you came to America
because you saw the values that the
American right has and thought well
these align more with my world view
therefore I want to be here
yeah to an extent I think I mean I grew
up in a household with a mom who's from
the US and she grew up as in this very
um strict Catholic household where there
was n billion children and you know I
guess my grandparents didn't have a
tremendous amount of time for her and so
she kind of wanted to give my brother
and me the freedom that she never had
growing up so while we had instilled in
us the same value system that my mom had
which you could argue was more of like a
you know Christian conservative value
system we still had my dad on the other
side of things who's not that he's like
a country boy that's you know from rural
wa rural Western Australia and just is
kind of like yeah she'll be right and so
when I moved to America I felt like I
fit in a lot but I'm realizing like I
don't in a lot of ways because I'm an
atheist for example like that seems to
be such a such a weird thing that some
Americans have trouble wrapping their
heads around because they think that if
you don't follow their you know
ideological value system then you must
be against them which is really
disappointing and I really dislike that
about living in the United States not
all Christians like that like lots of
them are so warm and loving like
tomorrow I'm going to go to church with
one of my girlfriends cuz she's like as
long as you're in town we should go to
church and I was like okay as long as I
don't burst into play walking through
the door um so yeah know there's things
that there's things about living in
America that have made the move easier
and that's why I did move yes but then
there's other things I've realized over
time that I'm like wow nope I'm
definitely definitely not a yank that's
so interesting I mean one of the things
I've noticed is you actually don't talk
that much about politics nowadays you
talk about societal issues and things to
do particularly with women which I
actually find very interesting you did a
video about birth control and I see a
lot of people we've had Louise Perry on
the show Mary Harrington on the show um
and people are starting to I think
recognize that the the pill in
particular yeah is having and has had
over a long period of time now very
significant effects on society can you
talk to us about that so for me
personally without getting into too much
detail um I was on birth control for a
very long time for many many many years
and when I was coming off of it because
there was no necessity in taking it I
thought okay this will be easy you just
come off of it it's all straightforward
and you know you're done and dusted lo
and behold it's not and it's not a
simple you just stop taking it one day
and everything goes back to normal your
body has changed after being on it for
so long and what I realized talking to
other girlfriends of mine was that they
also were experiencing these awful awful
side effects of being on birth control
and so you sorry Sydney like when we
talk about side effects what we talking
about here so for example there's a myth
that if you are taking birth control for
your skin for example and you come off
of birth control your skin will continue
to be fine for me and for many other
women that I know your skin goes crazy
and it stays crazy some women it doesn't
and they go back to normal so to speak
for me my skin has never been the same
um there's issues with with lito that a
lot of women face so they basically
experience either a complete drop off
where in a way and I hate to use this
terminology because I know that it's
it's like so steeped and leftism these
days but they almost experience like an
asexual where they're just totally
disinterested and not for a lack of
wanting to be interested they want to be
with their partners and they want to be
invested in that but they're just not
and even I was researching recently
because I thought surely there's
supplements and things that you can take
to sort of circumvent and combat some of
the effect
um in the body from taking the pill and
even I was reading that there's a thing
called The Sex binding hemoglobin that
you have at a four times higher rate
that's made in the liver when you stop
taking birth control we have it at a
higher rate than women who've never
taken it and I thought it's just it's so
sad to me that no one walks you through
these things and so that's why I wanted
to talk about the pill uh initially when
I started making well I've made one
video about it I have a couple others
planned and it's because I feel like
women aren't told from the outset what
the negative side effects could
potentially be I mean it's sort of sold
as this lifestyle drug oh you take it
for your skin you take it because you
might you know you might want bigger
breasts or whatever the case is and I'm
not sure how I feel about women doing it
for you know purely aesthetic reasons
but um no one no doctor that I've ever
spoken to has been like oh yeah it will
totally mess with you and it changes
things no one ever says that and I think
we're just being so let down by by
Society in this capacity it makes me
really sad well Harrington I think made
the point that when we had her on the
show that the main effect the main sort
of method of action of this birth
control was that it made her not want to
have sex well that's it it kills your
libido it just destroys it and you go so
wait a minute I'm taking this thing
every day this like big chunk of you
know of hormones to stop me from getting
pregnant so that I can have you know not
casual sex but you know Freer sex so to
speak and yet I'm totally disinterested
and I do not care about the opposite sex
because that's where you get to that
your brain you it's like you look at men
and you just think I like I'm I'm you
know a straight heterosexual woman I
love men I think they're wonderful but
you know there was a period where I was
like I don't care if I ever interact
with one physically ever again the pill
made you a
feminist that was it I was like y let's
grow the armpit hair it's Grim though
it's so grim and then you know I think
back to the Doctor Who prescribed this
to me when I was 18 17 18 and I think
could you just not have warned me just
slightly you know there there's I think
doctors are letting people down quite a
lot especially female doctors they
should know better yeah it's a great
point because we don't talk about the
side effects of the pill no and it just
seems that the moment a woman in the
west reaches a certain age yeah that
seen as a de facto thing to do yeah it's
like the responsible thing right and if
you don't do it if you don't participate
in taking these hormones then you're
seen as sexually um what's the word
irresponsible yeah and it's it's also is
that people have underlying conditions
that if they take the pill that might
mean that then they're more prone to
getting cancer for instance etc etc and
because we don't know certainly in the
UK where we don't scream people properly
MH you know you just taking this this
thing without being aware that actually
it could have some pretty dire side
effects for you yeah definitely I mean I
don't judge women who take it for like
say polycystic ovary syndrome or for you
know really really really heavy periods
and things like that I think there are
some women who do benefit from it um
whose systems were very out of whack
from the outset and so having these
hormones regulating whatever's going on
I mean I I can support that to a large
extent what I think is sad about even
that though is that it's just masking
symptoms of an rather than looking at
the underlying reason and obviously
that's not for everybody but it is for a
large portion of girls I know women who
who are on the pill for polycystic OV
syndrome and I've said to them like have
you explored like other avenues
potentially that might be more
beneficial to you than just taking this
little pill every day that might cause
you to have other effects and and I
guess it's the weighing up thing right
these women weighed up and they go no I
want to combat the side effects that
come or you know the horrible symptoms
that come along with these conditions
it's worth it to me whereas personally
like looking back I I wish I'd never
done it I wish I'd never done it does it
change how you think yeah totally oh yes
absolutely when you come off of the pill
it's it's quite crazy like the brain fog
lifts and you're suddenly able to think
rationally my mom would always make the
joke that I was perfect as a teenager
until I turned 17 18 and then I went
crazy and that coincides with me
starting to take both control and I know
that she's correct to a large extent
it's so sad to say but I was a lunatic I
it was like I couldn't regulate my own
feelings and so I was just this crazy
person walking around and then when I
stopped taking it I noticed that I just
became a person again I was able to
think clearly I could interact I could
articulate myself and I hadn't had that
for a really long time because birth
control actually changes as well the
type of men that you find attractive
yeah yeah there's um some some
scientific research uh about phons and
things like that so that if you I mean
there's there's one I'm trying to not
butcher the language that these actual
scientists have used um but there was a
woman whose name is Sarah Hill I believe
um and she wrote a book about this and
also did a really great Ted Talk that
everyone should watch um and she
basically says that estrogen loves
testosterone so if you have a high level
of estrogen I mean like these these
things will dictate these particular
hormones will dictate what kind of
partner you find attractive and so women
who are on the pill they've found um in
some of these studies that these women
will find men with lower or fewer
testosterone markers which is so
interesting to me so I love telling my
boyfriend I always say like well this is
why I love you now because you know I'm
not on the pill so it means you're a
nice masculine voice I'm sure he likes
that very flatting for him but it kind
of says a lot potentially about the
direction of society yeah uh and we know
testosterone levels in men are dropping
with every generation anyway that's
related though like I've thought about
this a lot where you have a lot of uh
estrogen I think in the environment and
and there's some crazy conspiracy
theories about how there's estrogen in
the water because women take the pill
and all these type of things I don't
know how I feel about any of that it's
turning the Frog guy yes yes turning the
men gay no so I wonder if there is a
correlation and a relationship there
because if women are selecting Partners
who are less masculine so to speak it's
obviously not that straightforward but
so to speak would that mean that men
then are adapting to that and becoming
in and of themselves last masculine that
creates an evolutionary pressure right
right yeah I and I don't know if that's
a completely crazy I don't think that's
that crazy to put out on the table yeah
I actually by the way I know the fact
that it came from Alex Jones wasn't
helpful but the frogs gay thing I mean
there is some truth to the fact that
there's more estrogen in the environment
and that changes a lot of things a lot
of people put it down to our overuse of
microplastics yeah I mean there's
there's a bunch of reasons um for the I
guess current makeup I don't know the
correct terminology um you know when it
comes to the hormones in the environment
and yes you're exactly right like
microplastics are a big one there was a
one specific spe ific chemical though
that was relating to turning the frogs
gay and it's like now a certified yes
this is the effect that this has on the
environment but I can't remember which
one it was I think it because it an a I
don't know well the Frog lgbtq
community's got to be very happy with
that pump more of that into the water
abolutely Sydney but we're talking about
men and women which is a really
interesting subject as well uh and I
know you you have some views on how men
are portrayed in society and all of that
and that that was something we wanted to
talk to you about as well yeah um I
think my views have shifted quite
significantly in the last number
experiences um yeah yeah I used to be I
used to be aggressively Pro men to the
exclusion of women I think in some sense
I used to think that I was quite
moderate on a lot of issues and now
looking back and seeing some of the
people who've entered the red pill space
and trying to comp compare myself to
them I think I hope I never sounded like
this cuz this is really yucky and un ful
um but yeah no the reason I care about
men's issues is because I think that a
lot of them get brushed aside and
brushed under the rug uh because there
is this prevailing attitude that men do
have to be the strong silent types and I
don't know how helpful that is but
equally I think that if you let that run
too far like the over it's so hard to
articulate the
over the over support of some of these
issues can in turn just lead to can I
swear on your show you can yes just
[__] on women and I think that's not
even a strong S I can't believe she
checked I thought she I thought the the
the the C was going to come out she's ay
oh I might yeah [__] I mean that's
not even that's me in the car I'll be
driving like you're [__] seriously
like Australian women are basically men
with more empathy like some of the
things that I've just that I've been
told by Australian women I'm like Oh my
like
what let's not go you don't want to hear
this story I promise you it's terrific
terrific oh so you met an Australian who
said something crazy yeah yeah yeah
absolutely yeah no hold bar no that's
not uncommon though so what you guys
okay you guys are from the UK where I
feel like your crazy people are way
worse than our crazy people by are you
mean Aussies yeah yeah but I think what
Francis and I are saying is on average
your Society is more crazy than the UK
one I don't know about maybe at the
extreme level the tail ends you may be
you know what you're probably right
you're probably right yeah
yeah and look D look Dan Andrews I mean
God bless his cotton but that was mental
what went on in Melbourne was AB he's
gone now they he he resigned he resigned
didn't he yeah but anyway let's come
back to the [__] yes yeah so so this
is quite it's it's really hard for me to
articulate because I think that there's
a lot of significant male problems that
do deserve the Limelight and they
deserve to be considered uniquely and
separately to women's issues I really
believe that and I've seen that in in
practice you know there's major issues
when it comes to um Divorce Court
there's major issues when it comes to uh
child custody there's so many things
male suicide male loneliness so many of
these things that are they're just so
widely overlooked and when men complain
about it people go well too bad how sad
you're never going to get preferential
treatment here the trouble though is and
this is what I'm noticing when you talk
about those things enough and this is
why I dislike the Andrew Tates of the
world and some of these red pill people
who've come up in recent years rather
than saying men and women have unique
problems that must be addressed
independently of each other in order to
fix them and some of them yes let's
support each other and come together on
them instead what happens is well men
have it really hard or or women have it
really hard let's hate the opposite sex
and I hate that I hate when feminists do
it I think it's so ridiculously
unhelpful because men are wonderful we
need men Society functions way better
when we have men around and the same
goes for women you have these people who
were like well I had a horrible negative
experience going through divorce court
with my ex-wife and now I just think all
women are garbage trash people who are
going to take all of my money it's like
sir no and that's such an odd way of
going about viewing the world it's like
you're looking you're looking behind
every corner waiting for someone to just
stab you and I I just I just don't
understand why people follow people who
make them feel that way it's validating
their Prejudice I think yeah and also
what these people are doing some of the
people that we're discussing is they're
monetizing resentment yes yes that's
exactly it that's such a good way of
putting it basically what they're doing
is they're drumming up all this hatred
they're riling up these bases of people
who are so lost and angry and they're
making money off of it and I'm like
you're so gross at least when I was
making my content and I still talk about
men's issues now it's just to a lesser
extent because I do feel like women are
kind of getting the raw end of the deal
in a lot of ways particularly with you
know with relation to the trans movement
and whatnot um but when I would talk
about men's issues I always tried to
make the point of saying we are just
better together Society just functions
way better when men and women can work
it out and support each other this is
what I always say I always I say any
ideology and I'm glad you mentioned that
it happens on both sides because it does
any ideology that wants to pretend that
men and women are the relationship
between men and women is best described
as a
conflict any ideology that wants to push
men and women apart is cancer it's
absolutely toxic and and their forms of
feminism not all of them but there are
forms of feminism that do that and a lot
of the red pill stuff that's coming out
now you're just going and and and I'm
looking at a lot of these people and and
what I don't understand is why people
don't look at the people who are saying
this stuff and go would I want to be
like you yeah I this is the other thing
too and and I'm going to try not to come
after my own team too much talking to
you guys because I find that one of one
of the things I've noticed and this is
why why I've withdrawn quite
significantly from you know the
conservative movement because I realized
that I don't fit in there they probably
don't want me anyway so now I'm just
kind of this right-wing person who
oscillates between libertarian and
whatever else welcome to the controlled
opposition um the one thing where we are
exactly that that's why that's why I was
like at least talking with you guys I
feel comfortable saying this stuff
because I know that you are on the same
page to an extent and even if you're not
you won't be buttholes about disagreeing
whereas I have been in some situations
where I've been asked a simple question
uh about these topics I answer it as to
the best of my ability um without trying
to insult anybody or be unkind or
whatever the case and people act like I
have just burned down their house and I
just
think how how as a society are we
supposed to evolve if we can't talk
about the issues even within our own
communities and one of the things that I
have noticed recently and this is one of
the very sad things is that a lot of the
female not only commentators but and
pundits and whatnot that I know who are
on the right but just girlfriends of
mine who are right-wing or you know
conservative whatever they're shifting
away from from this ideology because
they're like I'm not wanted here like
everything gets passed off as me being a
problem or this is a problem and so when
you talk about the red pill people and
the way that they behave and the way
that they sort of postulate and present
themselves you do think would I want to
be like this and the trouble is that
it's exactly like that for some
conservative people who who say all
these things on the internet they say
all these things to their audiences they
do their talks and their shows and
whatever and then behind the scenes they
live a completely contradictory life and
I think it's just so ridiculous to me
that you're out here trying to divide
people so aggressively when you yourself
are not even living by the same value
system that you try to enforce upon
others and a lot of that again comes
down to women must be subservient women
must be this women must be that don't
marry a hoe don't do all these things
and I think oh my God like if people
only knew how you behaved in your own
time in your personal life they would
have a completely different perception
of all the crap that you're saying but
would they Sydney or would they be like
this is our team screw the other team
this is my boy he's sticking it to them
probably there's a large portion of
people who would still be like like that
um this is why the Andrew Tate stuff has
just totally thrown me for a loop
because people always go well I want to
know when someone's a bad person and
then you have all these people going
well here's him basically self-reporting
that he's not a great person I mean
should we not listen to words that have
come out of his own face and they go no
no he didn't mean it like that and they
justify justify justify and I go so how
can you fix the issues in your own
Community if you can't even call out the
bad faith
actors we'll be back with Sydney in one
minute but first we want to tell you
about our sponsor fume if you want to
break your bad habit you can forget
about having to go cold turkey there's
now a better way we're talking about
fume it's spelled Fu M and pronounced
fume which makes no sense anyway not
everything in a bad habit is wrong so
instead of a drastic uncomfortable
change why not just remove the bad from
your habit fume is an Innovative
award-winning flavored air device that
does just that you can trade breathing
in nasty chemicals for breathing in
Fresh Air instead of vapor fume uses
flavored Air instead of electronics fume
is completely natural and instead of
harmful chemicals fume uses delicious
flavors it's a habit you are free to
enjoy and makes replacing your bad habit
easy your fume comes with an adjustable
airflow dial and is designed with
movable parts and magnets for fidgeting
which gives your fingers something to do
which is helpful for de-stressing and
anxiety
while breaking your habit I'll be honest
I didn't know what to expect with few
but they're actually more flavorful than
I thought and it actually feels fresh
the feel of them is nice it's well
weighted perfectly balanced and they're
made from real wood which feels nice and
looks good too fume has served over
150,000 customers and has thousands of
success stories there's no reason that
can't be you join fume in accelerating
Humanity's breakup from destructive
habits by picking up the journey pack
today head to
tr.com and use code trig to save 10% off
when you get the journey pack today
that's TR R yfu m.com and use the code
trig to save an additional 10% off your
order today give it a go it might just
help you kick that bad habit now back to
the
interview well I do find it odd uh with
Andrew T because I I haven't consumed a
lot of his content but I did see him I
saw him once talking about how a father
is supposed to be sort of turn up once a
year and be the and
and whatever I but that's not a
conservative world view no it's not and
the fact that conservatives are
embracing that I find very strange
defend him and also I mean I don't
remember a time in the history of
humanity when being pro pimping was a
conservative position right you know so
so he can do whatever he wants and
people can consume his content and I've
got no you know people can do whatever
they want on the one hand on the other
hand why people who espouse Traditional
Values would back that that's what I
find very strange because it justifies
the way that they live their own lives
behind the scenes that's why there's a
lot of are you talking about pundits
because there's a lot of people I think
uh who have quite large audiences on the
right
who emulate what Tate says but behind
closed doors and that's a real problem
now I'm not saying that you can't be a
flawed human being like I'm as flawed as
they come I've done a heap of crap that
I look back on and I go who let me have
the brain who let me out of the house
and it's embarrassing to think back on
but I like is right you should stay in
the house I should just be chained to
the
kitchen it's well there you go he has
you know a broken clock is right what
twice a day um but it's I look back on
my own life and I go oh I've been a
[__] and I've done moronic things and
and I'm ashamed of some things and but I
think that's like the regular Human
Experience right like who goes through
life going I did everything correctly
100% of the time absolutely no one so
I'm not saying that you can't make
mistakes or you can't learn from them or
you can't even say to your audience you
know hey I did this dumb thing it was
one of the dumbest things I've ever done
let me tell you about it and let's learn
from it and maybe I can help someone
along the way that's also really great
and I really love when people do things
like that my my problem comes with the
selling people a bill of both Goods
that's where my issue is and so I think
that's I just I really dislike the
Andrew
Tate phenomenon phenomena that's
happening I don't like it and I I just
think it's generally UNH hopeful the one
thing we should say as well whatever you
think about him is he is a symptom of a
problem yeah he's not it's not his fault
that people listen to him it's the fault
of a society that has suppressed healthy
masculinity for a long time i' agree
with and so he's the one that's prepared
to this is why Jordan Peterson was
successful very different characters by
the way I have a lot more interest in
Jordan imagine if Jordan just did
streams of his top off smoking
cigars chest T do you find that like I
find it so funny how people be like this
is so masculine and I'm like this feels
like vaguely what what like my gay
friends do they sit around and are like
You' got cute
pcks and
it's you know what I mean I don't know I
don't think that that's like a do dudes
do that do guys just like hang out with
each other shortless like smoking cigars
like this is the most masculine thing I
mean not
in Britain no in Britain we don't do
that maybe there's probably some Chads
in America that sit around smoking
cigars you used cigarett and
disappointment in the UK is that say
again you just do cigarettes and
disappointment yeah yeah that's what we
do I can't imagine people in scum with
their tops off smoking cigar smoking no
I don't see that I I've never seen this
in Texas either like I I come into
contact with uh with men all the time my
boyfriend has a bunch of male friends
that are you know this type of guys and
uh yeah not not a once have I seen any
of them shortless except my boyfriend
obviously you know self-explanatory you
I I agree with with what Constantine
says about Tate and the reason that he
rose to prominence is the fact that our
culture is has a vacuum is yeah is is
broken MH but also as well to me it just
speaks of men who aren't in control of
their lives angry yeah can't date the
women that they want to date yeah and
then you've got this guy who goes well
women are basically [__] and this is
what you need to do in order to get one
and then punish her yes I agree um and I
think there's a there is a big vacuum
and it's funny that you bring up Jordan
Peterson because I've had this
conversation with male friends of mine
where I've said to them like give me
your take on this I feel like part of
the problem is that there was Jordan
Peterson who people could actually
emulate because he's worthy of being
emulated he had good messaging he had
sound messaging logical messaging and
even if you didn't agree with it 100%
you could still take bits and pieces and
make it make sense and be like okay this
is still applicable to my life and then
he kind of fell off because he obviously
had some personal issues going on and
whatnot and then there was this vacuum
where men were still being abused
socially but being told that you know
the way that the ways that they behave
are not acceptable that they need to
change and shift and do all these sort
of things in order to fit in with
society and I think what that speaks to
is the fact that there's no male role
models that are
worthy of replacing like a Jordan
Peterson there's no one who's really
stepped up to the plate that has good
messaging has a good moral framework
whatever that looks like for the
individual and is able to talk to men at
their level and so instead what you get
are these Andrew Tate type figures who
have filled that void because no one
else could fill it and so in a way we
kind of created this monster ourselves
oh definitely but I actually don't agree
with you I don't think that's the
mechanism by which it was created I
think the mechanism by which it's
created is you have have to be a Milo or
an Andrew Tay or someone like that to
pierce all the [__] that people are
going to throw at you if you advocate
for a different world view than the one
that you're supposed to have in society
so for example a normal person comes
along like a Jordan Peterson and think
how much [__] he took right he's not
surprised that he he had the personal
problems that he had given look we are
all in the public eye to a much lesser
extent you know what it's like people
coming after you writing hi pieces about
you imagine that but every day times 100
yeah right that's pretty [__] brutal
so you have to be a psychopath or a
sociopath to be able to deal with that
no you do right and so then people will
come along who are just able to ignore
that completely and they just they just
go hard every time and I think that's
why because a much more moderate person
will likely be destroyed by the system
that's there and it takes someone who
who's just a Berserker who's going to
crash through that wall well I also
think some of these people have cult
leader Tendencies and it's they surround
themselves with people who are able to
do damage control for them and so in a
way they sort of feel Untouchable
because when they are criticized it's
it's hard to again it's hard to
articulate it's almost like they won't
let it they won't let it enter their
sphere and they make someone else deal
with it I don't know I I I I know a lot
about like the Andrew Tate situation and
sort of the way that
he's I guess yeah protected himself with
this group of acolytes so to speak um
and it's really really disconcerting
when you when you read about it I
haven't read anything about this well
basically with his
um I can't remember the name of it his
his like the real world no no his
website where he was basically
collecting people and they would pay him
to basically get advice on how to do
things from that came about like his
core group I feel like every one of
these people like Fuentes some of these
other people they have a core group that
they surround themselves with oh he
calls it the War Room doesn't he yes yes
the War Room yes so in his war room
that's like a group of trusted people
who will basically do a lot of things to
make sure that they sort of keep things
away from him they'll say oh this
person's lying that he like has bot
Farms that come out and respond to
things when you're critical on the
internet so they're constantly running
interference when there's actual
criticism of him and I notice this a lot
cuz there's a couple accounts that I
follow who constantly try to expose him
him and put out information you have all
these people who respond to it and go
this is not true you're lying they're
really good at running their own
interference yeah he is he is masterful
at what he does and how he has
incentivized people to share his content
yeah to the point where actually it
doesn't matter if Andrew gets
deplatformed no because he incentivizes
people financially yes to share his
content and every time they share his
content then someone signs up to his
website they get a percentage or a cut
of the fee to actually what he's done
from a strategy point of view it's
brilliant it's
brilliant the thing that's incredibly
worrying is that you look at the message
and you go this is toxic and divisive
yeah
and look you go free speech Free Speech
free speech of course of course of
course but when it affects young boys
and some of them as young as 12 who are
getting inculcated with this stuff y
it's incredibly worrying yeah I saw a
thing the other day that someone posted
it was a woman who' made a Tik Tok
basically talking about how she broke up
with her boyfriend because he was
getting too into the red pill sphere and
all these people were saying well that
guy dodged a bullet and all this type of
thing and some of what she was saying
was crazy like I admit that and I
watched it and I thought I like I I've
seen this Dynamic actually play out in
my personal life with friends of mine
who have broken up with guys and it's
like what went wrong oh well suddenly he
had all these bizarre opinions about how
our relationship should be and you go
where what's the origin of those
opinions oh well he's been consuming
this person's content this person's
content and so I just think
General the general disrespect that gets
facilitated between the Sexes because of
this really really disturbs me like I I
feel so lucky in so many ways that the
man that I have chosen to do life with
doesn't engage with any of this the only
person that he watches is Rogan and
benir that's it he doesn't care about
anybody else he doesn't want to listen I
tell him the things that I read on the
internet and he goes that is bad that
[__] people think that I'm like yeah oh
my goodness like here listen and he's
like oh god well this is the thing I was
saying earlier which is I think the way
that you got to choose Your Heroes
carefully yeah and the way to choose
Your Heroes
is to achieve the life that they have
yeah when I look at Rogan happily
married two kids very successful great
friendships built a scene here and you
know he's a he's a wonderful guy very
kind very generous Shapiro family Family
Guy like that's that's what I want right
that's what I always wanted and so to me
if that's I don't want Andrew Tate's
life I've never wanted that no uh I
don't want Pearl's life or or any other
any other oh yeah I forgot that you guys
interviewed her we did yeah we
did is that fun did you love that you
know what uh we didn't really know what
to expect it was one of those where we
uh we normally vet our guests quite
carefully to work out whether they're a
good fit for the show and this one was a
good friend of mine was like you should
have this person on and we were like
okay thanks mate cheers mate I
appreciate it uh yeah it was it was
awkward because we just it it was hard
to uh it was hard to have a conversation
yeah that was um challenging to
watch um I notic some people are like
this feels like a struggle session but
it's
like the reason see everyone that
criticized us for how we conducted that
interview completely misunderstood lots
of people think that we got triggered by
you guys didn't seem upset no we weren't
upset at all but what what we do is if
you say something that doesn't make
sense we're going to follow up to work
out why it doesn't make sense and so
when we were asking about why she had
Nick Fuentes on her questions her
answers to our questions made less and
less sense with every answer so we were
like let's keep digging let's find out
what's going on um and and and asking
why you had Nick Fuentes on if you've
apologized for it is a perfectly
legitimate question it's not as being
upset about her she's allowed to have
anyone on that she wants yeah but we're
allowed to ask why she had them on and
so that was all but anyway my my point
is you if you're choosing the people
that you want to follow Whose advice you
want to listen to in my opinion the
wisest thing to do is look at their life
and go do I want my life to look like
this yeah and if you look at Andrew
Tate's life if you're a teenager I'm
sure that's very appealing but once you
kind of get past that that's not a great
L well even if you want a meaningful
relationship like half of the half of
the core pieces of advice that some of
these people are giving like for example
test your girlfriend cheat on
her in what in what world in what world
is that is that logical to anybody oh
you know if she stays with you she loves
you no if she stays with you she has
Stockholm syndrome like this is this is
not complicated so in a way it's it's
almost like they're trying to create a
subservient group of women and a free to
do whatever they want group of men I'm
confused by the women who follow these
men because I think this is so
counterintuitive to your existence this
is so odd this is so
denigrating yeah they they really
confuse me but you were a little bit in
that direction at one point right I I'm
not saying this as a got you I just want
to explore why someone might behave that
way that's why no well so this is this
is what I was saying previously which is
that I don't know if I was ever on this
psycho plane of existence that some of
these other people operate what I was
hoping to do was call attention to
issues that affect men and get into the
Weeds about the validity of how those
men are affected but I would always try
to make the point of well you know for
example like let's talk about um men
being like sexually assaulted for
example it does happen uh well it
depends actually on the situation but
generally it does happen at a lower rate
than women um or men going to prison for
example for like really violent crime if
I was talking about a thing that related
to men and women going to prison I would
say you know like shorter prison
sentences that women often get for the
same crime I would always make the point
well women actually don't commit violent
crime women commit this kind of crime
and this is why you know sometimes you
see a difference and whatever so i'
would always try to at least caveat and
say this is why these things are
different even though it appears to be
unfair to men or men are being
mistreated in whatever capacity um I
think the I think the ideology for me
was that I just genuinely don't want the
men around me and the men I love and men
in my extended Circle to feel bad I
don't want them to feel how I currently
feel as a woman in the right-wing space
I don't want them to feel like that ever
in existence and so that's why it was
really important for me to talk about
this but I was never on the same
wavelength as people like I was never
like the women are the and you got you
got to chain her to the stove sir like
no I was never on that wavelength and I
never could be S do you think Sydney it
could be this I think maybe someone's
spok about it I don't know but if you go
on social
media you feel emotions over a period of
what half an hour to maybe an hour that
you would only get in the most intense
months of your life yeah you might feel
the need to cry you will get angry you
will laugh hysterically you'll get
triggered you'll want to get into an
argument and a debate and if you look at
what Andrew does it's not really about
the cerebral it's about emotion look at
this body don't you want this body this
is how you get this body don't you want
this car you want this car this is how
you get this car look at look at this
baby in the Bikini don't you want the
baby in the bikini and it's it's nothing
to do with this it's all to do with
activating the gut and essentially the
lizard part of the brain that lives
inside you know every human being but
certainly inside every man yeah no I
think that's a great observation I would
put it back to you guys as actual men do
you think that that more emotional side
of things actually appeals to men a lot
more because I love it how people always
say and they say this especially in
relation to the women shouldn't vote
repeal the 19th which is like and I I
have tried not to come at people over
this especially like some again other
female com commentators you say this
crap I'm like well maybe you should lead
by example ma'am and take yourself off
the internet if you really don't think
that women should have a say in
political discussions okay um but so
people always make the argument women
are too emotional I would make the
argument everyone's emotional it just
depends on the issue and men and women
display emotions totally differently um
so when it comes to what you're
describing that sort of visceral
response that men get to seeing you know
the beautiful woman or wanting the
six-pack or wanting the pretty car
whatever the case is do you think that
that's actually their natural
ation I
I look testosterone is a state of
seeking hormone men are driven to be
high status we just are it's why we work
it's why we take risks it's why we
seek money career etc etc what I think
tap does very interestingly is he offers
shortcuts yeah and I think that's the
the genius the dark Genius of Andrew
tapate is I'm going to show you the
shortcut in order to get all of these
things that lizard brain wants and the
shortcut is Escaping The Matrix cuz if
you're plugged into the Matrix then
you're never going to achieve these
things or if you are it's going to take
a long time and you're going to be
struggling and no one's going to give
you respect but if you but you know if
you join this app or whatever it is that
he's offering you're going to get all of
this and I would say there is a way to
steal man the argument that he's making
which is if you abstract yourself from
this idea of the Matrix and you just go
well there is a system in in which you
are told certain things that you're
supposed to believe that are blatantly
not true right and you've been
marinating in this crap at school at
University in the media
Etc escaping that Matrix is not a bad
thing it's a question of what you then
do with that right and I also think to
answer your question men just like women
different right we had Aya um the she's
an escort and only fans model in here uh
a few days ago and she's just her
brain's just wired differently it's just
wired differently right oh that's
interesting you can just tell so it's
not she I mean the the most amazing part
of the inter to me was CU we're like two
normies trying to wrap our head around
her her lifestyle and everything that
she does and then I went you know you
make 100 Grand a month on only fans she
makes a 100 okay not every month are you
ready to
go you reconsidering your career no um
she she makes at some points 100K a
month I do it with the feet photos I
would I would if I didn't feel the weird
Shame about it yeah you know what we
talked about feet a lot that is a weird
fetish yeah it is feet is a weird fetish
but a lot of people have got it I mean
there's a couple people who a lot of
people have her P though it's nothing to
be proud of I don't I don't know I don't
get the feet like I don't understand the
aure of Fe I mean I think there's odd
things about men and women that we find
attractive that are not conventionally
attractive but feet I don't get it like
I have there's a couple people who and
like no shame to them like hey if this
is your thing so be it that email me a
lot just please just one little toes it
and I'm like no toes I'll pay you I'll
give you money and I'm like ,000 I'll
give you any photo of my toes that you
want I just don't think I have cute feet
and so I don't want to send them to
somebody there they're
anyway sorry did you have another point
on feet no I just I I I do judge look
you shouldn't you should be openminded
shameful and you should be you should be
you should feel terrible absolutely and
if you are one of those people don't
talk us we'll give we'll give it to you
for money yeah it's no problem anyway uh
syy you don't want to say that because
you're actually going to get emails yeah
but I'm happy I'll send a picture would
you do would you say
F I couldn't no look there's a lot of
per out there and I'm happy to help them
for money it's fine um no my point is so
Aya I said to you make loads of money on
only fans and you still do
escorting does she have Rel like sexual
relations with the people that she yes
she has sex sexual relations well does
she you know yeah she has sex with okay
cuz some people just hang out no no no
no she I mean she does some hanging out
but she also has sex with them so what I
was saying was she gets paid a [__] ton
of money on only fans but she don't and
I was like so you you like that means to
me you don't need the money really you
must like it and she's like you know
some people are wired differently right
some people want to be Genghis Khan some
people want to have a Haram yeah some
people are like that never been appeal
to me my thing I when I was a young man
17 18 I thought I need to find the woman
that I'm going to marry marry her and be
together for the rest of our lives and
we met at 18 married at 20 been together
ever since right I've never I don't want
the shiny car I mean maybe if I go fully
bold I will get one but uh you know uh I
never wanted that wait why does the
going fully bold mean that oh it's
compensation that's that's you just get
plugs you just go turkey and have the
Turkish you can't wait this isn't a
[__] personal
intervention but it's a compensation
mechanism that men will often use
particularly in middle age they'll get a
fast car whatever right never appealed
to me is that not to sort of like relive
though the fun and excitement of like
their 20s or is it you think it's to
compensate I think it's it's I think
it's a combination of the two I think
sometimes we live the older you get the
more routine that your life becomes yeah
and because it has to because you have a
job you have responsibilities and
sometimes getting in a car and you know
going in a sports car and going at a
fast speed that's invigorating makes you
feel young maybe he doesn't have a
driving LC I don't have a driving do you
actually not oh my God I bet you love
the tube no I'm learning how to drive I
hate the tube and I hate public
transport because it never works because
we're in the UK anyway yes so my point
is I think PE men are wired differently
like women however u i I suspect that
the
lifestyle that um people like Andrew Tay
are advocating would not be satisfying
to most men yeah in terms of the deep
internal well-being it it's it raises
your status and makes you feel like a
king and a conqueror and whatever for a
while but you know there's a lot of
evidence from like one night stands and
stuff men don't feel good about them
either women just feel disgust and shame
and whatever but on most of them some
don't some are wide differently but with
men it's the same actually yeah you know
it doesn't make you happy no you're this
is why um one of the things that's been
really interesting now that I have a
handful of red fim friends that have
come about with you know both of us
hating the current state of affairs when
it comes to like the train man's
movement and whatnot the way that it it
presents women one of the most
interesting things that one of those
women has pointed out to me is that
casual sex doesn't benefit women it
certainly doesn't benefit anybody but it
certainly doesn't benefit women and
we've almost been conditioned to think
that this disgusting feeling that you
experience after you've done something
physical with someone that you don't
really like all that much or that you
know you don't see you know you're not
going to be in a relationship with them
you have no interest in pursuing
something whatever whatever we've been
taught that that feeling of revoltion is
normal and that that's just how it goes
you know you're just being free you're
doing all the things you're experiencing
life well it's like I don't know why you
would ever want to promote that for
either sex and I'm not certainly one of
these people that says that you have to
marry the first kid that you date out of
high school like no go and experience
life that's fine whatever that looks
like to you but I just think it's like
be mindful of of what you're doing to
yourself and like the little bits of
your soul that you're giving away every
time you do something that actually
doesn't make you feel good but you
convince yourself is a is a benefit so
it's just sad sad it's just sad this
wanting to sleep with 8 billion women
thing is sad the one thing I have to add
at some point in this interview and I
guess it's going to be here is this
preoccupation that everybody also has
with body counts is revolting to me I
don't know if you guys feel similarly
you see it online all the time I'm so
over it because I think to myself if you
are actually going to judge somebody cuz
let's say that someone was I don't know
had a like a male friend of mine for
example we've talked about this he's had
relations with many many many women many
more than he would like and he said that
the primary reason he did that was
because he was so insecure he felt so
unlovable that he just did did his thing
and then never spoke to them again and
he said I would never want someone to
judge me based on that number because
that's not representative of who I am
now and I think that that's so true for
a lot of people but this odd desire to
know everything about your partner so
weird to me it's so weird like there are
some things I think that can be personal
I don't know why this it's just even
even calling it a body count is so
disrespectful because it basically takes
this intimate act and totally denigrates
it hey Francis do you want to protect
your privacy of course I do now that I'm
an International Celebrity who's
appeared on hit shows like The Joe Rogan
Experience I have to protect myself from
vicious people looking to tear me down
I'm the Michael Jackson of the internet
not the celebrity I would have gone for
but trust is important when picking a
VPN I don't trust anyone after she left
me she took everything Francis remember
what your lawyer said good point you can
trust expressvpn because they don't sell
your data to advertisers they've even
created software called trusted server
that means they can't store any data at
all expressvpn uses lightweight a VPN
protocol that makes user speeds faster
than ever express VPN is now blazingly
fast you can watch HD videos with zero
buffering thousands of pounds in legal
fees the great thing about expressvpn is
that you don't need any technical skills
to set up just like Francis fire up the
app and it's one button to connect One
Tap on a button was all it needed for my
entire life to
disintegrate loads of people are saying
that Express VPN is the best VPN there
is Business Insider The Verge and many
other Tech journals raid Express VPN as
the number one VPN in the world go on
Francis protect yourself with Express
VPN use our link
expressvpn.com trigger toay and get an
extra three months free on a one-year
package that's
expressvpn.com trigger visit
expressvpn.com trigger to learn more she
took
everything that is interesting because
women are more interested in their
partner's past like if I'm dating a
woman I don't want to know what she did
before I met her I think you're the
exception really I genuinely like I just
want it to be like you know like in a
Men In Black bang I don't know and I
don't want to know you can do what you
what you did and whatever else and that
was you in the past I don't want to know
and I don't care yeah I will confess I
would definitely want to know would you
yeah would it change something for you I
have no idea because it's a hypothetical
I'm never going to experience but um
it's count your blessings yes uh touch
wood or whatever but um I think from an
evolutionary perspective I do understand
it because um there is a reason cultures
tend to obsess about virginity
historically speaking it's about
ensuring that um you know promiscuity in
in in a woman is very very bad for the
man because it's about paternal
certainty right if your wife is a quote
unquote [__] or the partner you're going
to I I don't like that word I'm just
using um if then the risk to the man is
very high from a gene perspective
because you're going to be raising
someone else's kid as a man biologically
speaking that's a terrible place to be
right um so men have always obsessed
about virginity and all of that now it
doesn't make logical sense because the
fact that a woman has had sex with 10
men before you changes nothing but you
might argue it's a marker of her
potential behavior in the future you
could but I I'm not saying it is I'm not
saying people obsessing about body
counts as the right thing I'm just
saying I see how that might come about
from my evolutionary past do you see
saying I think yeah no of course no and
what you say about the paternal thing
makes total sense I think that we don't
we don't live in that current climate I
mean I get it from it's an inbuilt thing
but then I think that to a large extent
we kind of override some of those
natural processes because logically we
go I know if someone has had a child or
not because they I have one it's
physically here and I know it's not mine
um I guess it's more for me just this
this odd obsession with using these
things that men do as well that both
sexes do but using it as like a shaming
mechanism I just find that so strange
because it's I don't have any problem
with someone seeking out someone who's
had fewer sexual partners like I'm not
going to judge you for having a
preference that's okay I'm someone who
actually doesn't I don't care I don't
want to know I'm I'm just like you I do
not want to know do not tell me it's not
on my Bloody Business and I feel that
way um as well you know in relation to
being asked it's none of your damn
business because everything prior to
what happened before you and me in our
relationship that's past like we're done
unless it's something pertinent that you
need to know like you know someone has
venial disease or something which I you
know obviously you should disclose that
type of information but yeah it's just
it's really weird it's really weird to
me and they go on about it so much too
that's I guess another thing that I
notice is everyone makes it like a
central part of the conversation and I
think none of this instigates respect
and I think that if you're going to
actually amarate relationships between
men and women perhaps the starting point
should be building a foundation of
mutual respect do you think it might be
the Madonna [__] the the Madonna uh
Mary Magdalene kind of thing you know do
you see what I mean that a woman is
either a [__] or she's a wife who
should be respected who does nothing but
look after the children and bake all day
and look incredibly beautiful and Buxom
at the same time do you know what I mean
yeah no of course yeah it's it yeah
there is kind of that iconomy emerging
isn't it yeah um one of the saddest
things and and I want to be clear I
don't want all like right-wing
conservative men to get roped up in my
present feelings about the conservative
movement because I do recognize that the
men that we're talking about these
people and it's women too these people
that we're talking about are a fraction
they're a very loud fraction and they
think they're growing but they are quite
small and I think your average person
probably thinks like we do regardless of
sort of how they vote politically or
think politically overall my issue with
the dichotomy that you're talking about
is it leaves like no room for just
people being people and again it's this
thing where it's like if the woman does
it it's such a horrible negative she's
all these things she's a [__] she's a
[__] you know send her to the island
but if a man is to do it based on the
way that these men feel about it it's
just them you know being masculine just
them exerting themselves onto the world
and I think that's just yeah again it's
just I find a lot of this really
unhelpful yeah well it is and I know
that you've had some personal
experiences lately that probably have
changed how you view the way the right
in particular treats women yeah
definitely I mean my experiences
have definitely colored my view of
everything um I went through a period
probably towards the end of last year
the beginning of this year where I just
felt mad all the time because happened
Sydney tell people who who may not be
aware so I uh I don't know how much
detail I can go in just because of the
legal components to this but I was
involved um with a co-host on a show
with a network a conservative Network
and my experience was extremely
extremely negative I felt like there was
a lot of treatment that went on that was
negative because I'm a woman and I never
experienced that previously which is why
a lot of my you know earlier viewpoints
were
I was much more likely to call out silly
things that I saw happening from women
whereas now I kind of get where they're
coming from and I never had that
previously and so now I'm definitely
colored by it I don't like that I'm
colored by it though because I don't
want to be ever one of these women who
comes at life from this solely personal
vantage point is always passing judgment
on whatever situation based on my own
independent experiences and my own you
know traumas so to speak I don't know a
better word um does that make sense yeah
yes yeah well you don't want to be
walking around with a set of sh glasses
yes exactly I don't want to be all men
are whatever cuz it's not all men it's
one guy in this case right of well I
mean it's it's yes in that case one I
mean my experien is to be honest with
you now that I've sort of if I can be
honest about it there's there's a lot of
people like this that exists in the
world again I don't think that they
outnumber the normal people I always you
know I do believe that normal people
make up the majority um they just don't
concern themselves with a lot of this
but I do think that there are some
really toxic elements and really messed
up elements of the right wing but people
don't understand that these experiences
that I had are feeding into how I
presently feel and presently talk about
the environment that I'm in this
political environment the worst part is
and this kind of speaks to what we were
talking about earlier with relation to
you know relationships and body counts
and blah blah blah I have a couple
girlfriends um one of whom is a is a
decently well-known pundit so to speak
and she did all the right things married
babies blah and she feels like she got
such a crappy deal because she tried to
do everything by the book exactly how
they tell you to do it you know you find
the person you get married you have the
kids you try to be the stay-at-home wife
you try to do all these things and her
partner ended up doing some not okay
things in the relationship abandon the
relationship and now she's here holding
these pieces and she's going I don't
know how I don't know how to reconcile
these two things I don't know how to
reconcile the way my life used to be the
way that I used to think about the world
and now these broken pieces that I have
how do I put this all together to form a
coherent understanding of what's going
on around me and I feel like that
sometimes too where I I kind of look at
all the things that went down all the
things that happened and all the people
who get on the internet and say you're a
liar and you're a feminist and you're
just making this up you know in order to
to further your own ends which just by
the way if a woman uh particularly on
the right wing talks about a negative
experience particularly that relates to
sexual harassment or anything like that
there's kind of no net positive that
comes out of that because you can't win
you're automatically disbelieved and
even if you prove that your situation
actually happened as you said it
happened everyone will continue to call
you a feminist because you spoke out in
the first place and so this is why I
said before I don't want men to ever
feel how I currently feel and this is
why you know I I did my men's right
stuff and I still really care about that
but it's also why now I'm so
aggressively like listen there are some
significant bloody issues on the right
wing that we have to fix because if we
don't you're going to alienate the
living crap out of women you will never
have the support of of normal everyday
women because they're feeling alienated
the men then feel alienated because
they're like why are you behaving like
this and it just makes things so much
worse so yeah it's it's a problem with
the left as well with the left wing
where you get all these people going you
know # believe all women I'm a feminist
and then behind closed doors there's a
bit of gropey grope going on there's a
lot of that on the left like a lot yeah
and and we saw it with with our industry
so do you think it's a good time to be a
woman at the moment
Sydney
um yes and no um yes like overall I
think that we historic perspective not
too bad I was going to say like I don't
have to wear a burer um I can basically
drive a car uh badly but that's okay no
I mean like Yeah from historical
standpoint of course like we're living
through one of the greatest periods of
human history um I think that by and
large relations between men and women
are pretty good um do I think that there
are some things that need to be
addressed yes do I think that that
applies to both sides of the aisle yes
do I think that applies to both sexes
yes so I mean I'm not going to sit here
and like cry about the fact that you
know I I have you know particular
chromosomes that makes my life more
challenging where it sucks for us is the
trans stuff that's where it sucks um and
this weird like cohort of men that have
come out of like the Andrew Tate red
pill stuff like I just I want those men
to just evaluate where they're at and
perhaps stop dirting all their vitriol
just at women like some introspection
might be good all right Sydney you've
mentioned it a number of times and no
episode of trigonometry is complete
until we've talked about the trans stuff
the the the the the ladies of
trigonometry they demand trans it's like
a red blood red blooded male who wants
steak for dinner every night birds love
trans birds love trans is we don't have
to talk about it is the slogan of but
you brought up a few times so clearly
it's important to you well because it
affects me and I feel very strongly
about it and I'm always trying to like
reconcile that I have friends who are
trans or you know who I respect you
people that I know who I respect who are
transs and I'm always trying to like
reconcile how frustrated I am because on
in a lot of ways I
think I can't tiar everyone with the
same brush because that's just not how I
want to live my life but by the same
token
I kind of want to like I'm getting I'm
getting filled with disdain for a group
of people that you know I'm sure there's
a very large portion of them that just
want to be left alone oh for sure well
we had malice in here earlier today and
one of the things we talked about with
him is essentially that once you get to
the point where you're hurting children
yeah people are going to lose all sense
of nuance and their right to because if
you are teaching kids whatever that and
we've had you know Carol marcoz on the
to talk about what they're actually
teaching in American schools I'll be
honest with you lots of people are
saying you should move to Austin you
should move here you should move here
one of the main reasons that I'm not
interested is the education system in
the country terrible I do not want my
children to be exposed to that crap y um
so that once you get to that point uh
I'm like you know what I don't give a
[__] [__] you you know and that's not a
good place to be because there are
plenty of trans people who are decent
respectful they don't want to invade any
spaces they don't want children to be
taught to mutilate their body you know
we've had a bunch of these people on the
show and that's again an area where the
because the these Progressive ideas are
getting taken to the extreme ideological
conclusion yeah you get a backlash which
is something that we've always been
concerned about yeah I mean I think it's
a natural response to being told for
long enough that if you don't abide by
someone else's view of the world or how
they want to be viewed in the world
you're a bad person and I think it's
kind of funny because men don't get
smacked with this quite as much as women
do um I think really the only area that
men kind of get really messed up is when
it comes to dating like if you're
unwilling to be intimate with someone
who's trans like you're a bigot you're
all these things but you know what
there's probably not many guys who would
be like I really give a [__] what you
think well that's the thing men do not
care men don't care whereas the lesbians
I feel so bad I have a couple lesbian
friends and they're constantly like all
of the dating apps are just full of
biological dudes and they're like I just
want to be with a woman just I just want
to be with a woman like the end of the
sentence uh and I I I feel terrible I
feel terrible for the state of things my
primary issue really uh besides the CH
the children thing which is huge to me
like I I I used to talk about it a lot
and I've kind of peeled back a bit
because to be honest with you my heart
can't take it anymore the pedophilia
stuff and all all this type of thing um
I used to cover a lot of it just I've
got my sort of how are people hearing
this filter on so I know you're not
saying all trans people are pedophiles
just so people oh I wasn't making the
relationship I know I know you were so
what are you talking about specifically
so just in case people make that
connection by accident so previously
well on my channel um and just generally
I would always research particular areas
of child abuse and pedophilia and
whatnot to expose uh particularly like
minor attracted people or minor
attracted people groups as they call
themselves yes in order to uh in order
to basically shine a light and be like
here here's where this is happening
please pay attention um the second point
to that yeah I'm probably probably
didn't rightly articulate myself the
kids thing with relation to the trans
stuff mostly comes from I think the
lgbtqia XYZ stuff that's being you know
enforced on kids with the hey you know
if you think that you might be a boy
maybe maybe you are maybe you're not a
tomboy maybe you're not just again
atypical girly girl who just likes stuff
and has interests maybe you're a boy
that's the that's the trans component
I'm not I don't think all trans people
are pedophiles I know I know I just I
wanted that to be clarified so people
don't you know how people I appreciate
it yeah but I I think like as far as
being a woman living through this odd
really odd period of time my primary
issue besides the eer mentioned comes
from the fact that
nothing feels like it doesn't feel like
women have access to our own
spaces and so when we try to say hey I'm
not comfortable with being called CIS
I'm not comfortable with you calling me
a birther a breeder a menator a uterus
Hab I'm not comfortable with any of this
language I'm not comfortable with the
fact that I can't be sure that going
into a bathroom or a change room or
whatever I'm not going to come into
contact with these people and I've had
these experiences where I for some
reason the area that I live in there's I
keep running into trans people there all
over the place and again n times out of
10 I'll be very kind to you I've got no
reason not to be but as soon as I'm
trying to go into a public restroom and
I'm very very obviously sensing that
you're not a woman I'm I'm I'm
uncomfortable with that and people have
an issue with that they go why do you
care what bathroom these people use I
mean there's unisex bathrooms they've
always been a thing well I'm not
comfortable with men being in the same
space as me like in that capacity I'm
just not I don't like it I don't I don't
like unisex toilets oh neither do I I
really don't never got it I've never
understood that I went to this Swanky
restaurant with a mate of mine and I
went to the gender neutral bathrooms and
there was and there was a woman there
who was a mom with her young daughter
and you know they were doing things that
you do with a young daughter and I was
walking through I'm like I don't want to
be here I don't want to see this I don't
want to be around this I shouldn't be
here you're right M your feelings are
the most important yeah it is no but I
get it it's like this this just
discomfort in knowing that I mean and
and I don't feel like this because I
think that you know these people are
going to attack me or something like
that but there's a pretty significant
substantial history I think that we've
established that people will take
advantage wherever they can and if it's
so easy to identify as the opposite sex
and then gain access to their spaces if
you are somebody who is predatory then
who's to say that you're not going to
take advantage of that and behave in
that way like I I don't think that
that's so far outside the realm of
possibility and this is why it's sad
because you have normal trans people who
are like I feel intense discomfort with
my physical body and I do not want to be
like this who are trying to navigate
this messed up existence that that we're
all going through and there's this extra
messed up because they have this
psychological thing happening to them um
that's why I feel bad for those people
because they get caught up in the
genuinely terrible messaging and
genuinely terrible behavior and
genuinely terrible law and all these
type of things that get past that impact
regular people and impact women like
especially when it relates to the the
mother's thing and babies and you know
giving birth and these really really hyp
special things that relate specifically
to women and specifically to mothers the
sort of I guess undermining of that I
find that so unbelievably
offensive I mean pretending that men and
women aren't different has a lot of
cascading side effects absolutely out of
that Sydney it's been a pleasure thank
you so much for coming on the show uh
the last question we always end with is
what's the one thing that when well I
say that we're going to go to locals and
we're going to ask you some questions
from our audience uh but before we do
that the one thing we always ask is
what's the one thing that we're not
talking about as a society that we
really should be I'm actually going to
say the pill the pill and hormonal
imbalances in both men and women I think
that it accounts for so much of what
we're seeing today I think it accounts
for a lot of the depression and anxiety
and general mental disorders that you're
seeing in women and I think it's
obviously having a flow on effect to men
and I think that that is a conversation
that needs to be had and then the caveat
to that the second part is the Casual
Sex element this issue needs more
attention head on over to locals where
we continue the
conversation when the co vaccine first
came out I think I remember Sydney
speaking about being vacine injured by
the HPB vaccine yeah I just wondered if
it still affects her now I hope not and
how much influences has had on her being
so outspoken about the co
[Music]
vaccines